mesdames et messieurs bonjour irlande du
nord 13 morts par balles à londonderry
hier après-midi les parachutistes ont
tiré sur deux jeunes manifestants
catholiques nous allons avoir dans
quelques minutes une liaison avec la bbc
on nous annonce de très dur si mal
notons aussi que ce matin commence à
belfast les représailles après ce
dimanche sanglant représailles prévu par
les républicains irlandais de l'ira
trois attentats à la bombe à belfast et
dix blessés ce matin france une semaine
sociale importante
avec aussi la grève des journalistes qui
commence dès cet après midi marseille
hold up en plein centre de la ville tout
près de la canebière rue saint ferréol
ce matin un million cent mille francs
110 millions de centimes dérobé en
quelques secondes
le mauvais temps -11 degrés cette nuit
dans l'est c'est à dire plus froid qu'à
stockholm
et puis et d'abord ceux dont on va
reparler toute la semaine ça pour il ya
du nouveau
monsieur brundage président du comité
international olympique vient d'obtenir
la disqualification de l'un des plus
prestigieux des skieurs alpin
l'autrichien karl france
commençons par là c'est le coup de
tonnerre que l'on craignait pour ces
jeux olympiques d'hiver est un coup de
tonnerre qui vraisemblablement ne va pas
rester sans suite
le comité olympique a donc voté
l'exclusion du champion autrichien karl
schranz par 28 voix contre 14
c'est la thèse de monsieur brundage qui
a prévalu le respect de la tradition
olympique donc on reproche à fra nce
d'avoir gagner de l'argent avec ces skis
si c'est vrai et c'est vrai je rentre
lui même ne le cache pas pourquoi lui
seul et il exclut france qui touchait à
la fin de sa carrière
hal est en tous les cas à sapporo pour
la gloire
karl schranz 33 ans une carrière longue
de 17 ans et 17 ans après sa première
victoire internationale
il demeure le meilleur descendeur du
monde il était le grandissime favori des
jeux de sa peau autrichien né à sainte
entonne tyrol ici d'une famille très
modeste le ski comme pour la plupart fut
sa chance sa chance aussi sa rencontre
avec un fabricant de skis qui dirigea et
dirige toujours sa carrière bien sûr
france n'est pas un amateur au sens
olympique du terme mais à 33 ans et la
rage de vaincre le goût du risque
l'amour du ski qu'il anime encore
non l'appât du gain il allait à sapporo
pour la gloire tout le reste il le
possède le reste un hôtel à 500 tonnes
une bonne place dans une firme de ce qui
est des médailles et des coupes un
millier au total de l'année en 17 ans
d'une carrière extraordinaire
karl schranz fut trois fois champion du
monde remporté à deux fois la coupe du
monde à son palmarès les plus belles
descentes 8 fois celle du kandahar
quatre fois le lauberhorn à wengen trois
fois le hahnenkamm à kitzbühel rusé
homme d'expérience franz est surnommé le
vieux renard par ses adversaires ses
rivaux dont le français henri duvillard
son cadet de 10 ans chante ce qui
demeure le meilleur parce qu'en dépit de
son expérience s'entraîne toujours
davantage travaillant sans relâche sa
spécialité choisie par son courage son
travail sa ténacité ne méritait pas sa
disqualification
l'ensemble du problème les skieurs et
l'argent l'amateurisme aujourd'hui et la
veille de ces jeux olympiques de sapporo
édition spéciale d'hebdos sport par jean
paul soete et qui vient de dresser ce
portrait de france
tout à l'heure tout de suite après 13h
mais dans l'immédiat michel drucker
comment se fait-il que seuls 30 soit
touché c'est une affaire internationale
pour tout le monde cette année
gignac lui qui est exclu bien sûr et
france a d'ailleurs répondu à cette
question pourquoi moi car nous sommes
des professionnels officieux bien sûr
mais nous sommes tous il faut d'ailleurs
rappeler le texte de la dépêche qui est
tombé à 4 heures 15 ce matin chante et
donc disqualifiée pour quoi et bien
parce que la manière dont il a utilisé
son nom et sa photographie à des fins
publicitaires n'a pas pu bien sûr à
monsieur brundage pourquoi je pense
peut-être parce que c'est le vétéran
parce qu'il a 33 ans et ses teintes et à
titre d'exemple qu'on a frappé le skieur
de 50 tonnes en tout cas les autrichiens
et l'homme de la rue à vienne en
particulier ne l'entend pas de cette
oreille c'est une véritable colère qui
gronde en autriche je vous donne en bref
les dépêches qui sont tombés il ya
quelques instants dans les trams dans
les trains dans toute l'autriche on
parle bien sûr de la sphère france et
c'est naturellement monsieur brundage
ferme ce brunch que se tournent
essentiellement la colère et
l'indignation du peuple autrichien
on reproche aussi aux dirigeants
autrichiens leur tactique de ne pas
avoir fait essayer de faire un front
commun avec les dirigeants français
italiens et suisses pour justement
éviter ces disqualifications
à la veille de l'ouverture des jeux le
docteur synovate qui me lisent de
l'éducation nationale vous l'aurez sans
doute la dépêche sous les yeux parce que
je adressé il ya quelques instants à ses
homologues de france de suisse d'italie
et de la république fédérale allemande
une lettre de protestation contre la
décision prise contre eux car le chante
bien sûr le docteur synovate représente
cette décision comme arbitraire il
demande sa révision c'est le mou
révision qui revient d'ailleurs dans
toutes les dépêches maintenant à la
suite de l'exclusion de france de
comités n'implique que la fédération
autrichienne de ski a décidé de
suspendre à partir de demain matin
l'entraînement d'esker pour l'instant
suspens l'entraînement il n'est pas
question de retrait des équipiers de
france le comité national autrichien
demande de réexaminer la sphère chance
aucune décision sur un éventuel départ
de l'équipe d'autriche ne sera prise
aujourd'hui la délégation autrichienne
désirant gagner du temps et voulant se
ménager la possibilité de se mettre en
rapport avec le gouvernement autrichien
cela va de soi enfin monsieur committee
oui d'accord pas être ministre il n'y a
pas que les autrichiens les français
aussi sont là et ce doublé français ne
venge pas pour l'instant le ministre
mais ce que meetic s'est embarqué pour
tokyo il y a
orly a déclaré avant deux parties à la
disqualification de chance m'attriste
profondément
sans vouloir discuter les raisons qui
ont pu provoquer cette décision du cul
et olympique je la trouve tardive et
inopportune à la veille bien sûr des
épreuves dont le résultat sur le plan
purement sportif
et en ce qui concerne bien sûr la
descente sera certainement faussé car je
rentre vous le savez est actuellement le
meilleur descendeur du monde alors si
l'équipe d'autriche se retirer il n'y a
pas de chance il y as meissner il ya
corps ligne il ya de très très bons
spécialistes de la descente
si l'équipe d'autriche se retire les
jeux seraient faussés les français les
italiens et suisses se retire on s'en
doute nous serons dans l'après midi et
on reparlera peut-être de ces
championnats du monde de praloup oui
puisque si les olympiques ne pouvait pas
avoir lieu au japon
les skieurs alpins avait peut-être prévu
devrait la retrouver pour des
championnats du monde en eau se
rassemblent plus ce soir ou demain
l'irlande le sang a coulé à londonderry
hier après midi rien ne le laissait
prévoir c'était un dimanche comme tant
d'autres dimanche il y avait une
manifestation de jeunes catholiques
comme il n'y en a eu tant et tant depuis
quatre ans depuis 68 depuis la reprise
de la violence dans cette province
britannique
un cortège de jeunes catholiques
bernadette d'evelyne en tête l'armée en
face et puis soudainement c'est le drame
ce qui s'est passé hier nous rappelle à
nous français à plus d'un titre les
pires heures de l'algérie la fusillade
de la rue d'isly mars 1962 notamment ce
qui ne veut pas dire que l'inter va
maintenant retrouver son indépendance
les images que nous envoie la bbc
commentée par georges pitoëff pour les
catholiques ce dimanche est presque un
jour de fête
du moins c'est comme ça que cela
commence tout commence dans le calme
est ce un jeu alors que les catholiques
bravent l'interdît qui depuis plusieurs
semaines pèse sur toutes les
manifestations qu'elles soient
catholiques ou protestantes
ce dimanche ils sont dix mille peut être
vingt mille
la marche est organisée pour protester
contre l'internement administratif c'est
à dire l'arrestation arbitraire des gens
jugés dangereux
il est à peu près trois heures de
l'après midi aucun heurt avec les forces
de l'ordre pour l'instant
et puis brusquement les heurts éclatent
il est 3h30 à peu près de l'après midi
les catholiques qui ont voulu emprunter
une route une rue interdite par l'armée
lapitre le service d'ordre
le face à face dure 10 minutes à peu
près et puis c'est là sous l'assaut
donné par les troupes des engins blindés
et des hommes du 1er bataillon du
régiment de parachutistes des hommes
apparemment effrayés par cette tâche
1 81 million n'a pas encore tiré puis à
4h05 un premier coup de feu
on ne sait pas qui a tiré
l'armée réplique il ya 13 morts par
balles et cinquante ou soixante blessés
les noirs américains
il
qui a tiré le premier on ne sait pas les
officiers anglais affirme que les francs
tireurs ont commencé par tirer
les témoins irlandais est en tête
bernadette des films accuse ce [ __ ]
massacre pure et simple
l'armée tiraient sur tout ce qui
bougeait
la jeune député catholique bernadette
d'evelyne vient de partir pour londres
elle demande une réunion extraordinaire
du parlement
on ne sait pas qui a commencé ce que
l'on connaît c'est le nombre total des
victimes en irlande du nord en quatre
années de violence 231 morts et ce matin
à belfast je voulais signaler en
commençant ce journal ce matin commence
les représailles prévu par l'ira l'armée
républicaine irlandaise trois attentats
à la bombe l'un de ces attentats a fait
dix blessés
une forte charge d'explosifs a éclaté
dans un magasin en plein coeur de
belfast
voilà donc où on en est triste irlande
triste début de semaine triste suite
d'un conflit
quand finira t-il en france une semaine
difficile sur le plan social semaine ou
patrons patron gouvernement et syndicats
commencent l'épreuve de force de l'année
il y a en fait durcissement de parts et
dont le calendrier avec hervé chapelle
oui le coup d'envoi de cette semaine
sociale et donner cet après midi par les
cheminots qui rencontre la direction de
la sncf une nouvelle fois négociations
très difficiles les positions des uns et
des autres restant très éloignées en
matière de salaires et syndicats
réclament essentiellement une
progression du pouvoir d'achat pour 1972
de 2%
la direction offre un ennemi pour cent
et la cgt laisse planer une menace de
grève en cas d'échec de ces négociations
demain mardi discussions qui porteront
également sur les salaires mais chez
renault et aux charbonnages de france
là aussi il reste encore beaucoup à
faire pour rapprocher les points de vue
de la direction et des syndicats
mercredi les syndicats cgt et cfdt de la
région parisienne organisent une
manifestation de la bastille à la
république thème du défilé la sécurité
de l'emploi et la formation
professionnelle depuis également la
grève des journalistes oui cette semaine
donc la grève générale celle des
journalistes
en principe il n'y aura pas de journaux
écrits à paris en province à paris
demain à partir de demain puisque les
journalistes de la presse écrite ont
débrayé commence à débrayer à partir de
cet après midi et pour 24 heures les
journalistes de radio et de télévision
eux ne travailleront pas en principe
demain à la rtf radio et télévision un
service minimum sera assuré comme la loi
l'exigé
les syndicats de journalistes réclament
un plan national d'urgence
assurant et là je cite les termes de ce
syndicat l'existence l'indépendance et
la pluralité des moyens d'information et
les syndicats exige d'autre part que les
journalistes soient associés à la
préparation de ce plan l'union nationale
des syndicats de journalistes demandent
par ailleurs dans la sphère paris jour
la nomination d'un administrateur
judiciaire en vue de l'art parution du
journal
pour garantir les droits de chacun à la
bourse leur montrent toujours et nous
allons avoir la tendance de cette
première bourse de la semaine avec
gérard vidal anges on a frôlé en effet
on a frôlé le prix de 48 dollars à
londres et est un petit peu en deçà ce
matin mais le lingot aujourd'hui est à
7781 contre 7775 même cour pour le
napoléon
cela représente donc sur le marché libre
le de l'or une surcote en quelque sorte
de 25% par rapport au prix officiel sur
les valeurs françaises
on est assez sélectif avec même des
échanges de titres sont surtout
distingués ce matin la redoute pour
l'instant et le crédit foncier
voilà pour la tendance en quelques
minutes leur gérard merci à noter la
baisse d'un centime de naissance à
partir de demain en fait un centime
partout en france sur le super et un
centime sur l'essence normale selon les
régions je sais bien qu'en centimes
c'est peu mais comme les baisses sont
assez rares cela valait 15 secondes
cette baisse est due à la dévaluation du
dollar et à certaines différences sur le
prix du transport du pétrole
le hold up de marseille dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure marseille ce
matin donc un hold up qui vient en
quatrième position quant à l'importance
du butin sur les 32 devant registre est
en france depuis 12 mois
pas d'effusion de sang mais quelle
émotion tout près de la canebière
hold up audacieux ce matin à 8h15 rue
saint ferréol des gangsters armés et
masqués ont cerné une fourgonnette de
transport de fonds et tenu en respect
les deux convoyeurs et le chauffeur
montant du vol un million cent mille
francs pour deux témoins les commerces
souffrent en effet leurs portes
de plus tard dans la matinée les
automobilistes ont été bloqués l'un des
malfaiteurs ayant pris les clés de la
voiture située en tête de file à lyon ce
matin une action d'un tout autre genre
dix militants d'un groupe d'action
pacifistes ont pu pénétrer dans les
souterrains d'un pc atomique en voie
d'achèvement au mont verdun pour
manifester contre le système sécurité
aussi vulnérable mais aussi pour
protester contre l'action atomique du
poisson général et les ventes d'armes au
pays du tiers-monde
nous allons conclure avec le temps il
reste froid voyez les températures
enregistrées cette nuit je dis bien
cette nuit il faut aller en corse pour
trouver un + 5
il a fait aussi froid en alsace qu'à
stockholm bien sûr ce sont les
températures urbaine au mont blanc il a
fait moins 25 dans la nuit la météo
prédit de février ne sera pas
particulièrement rigoureux à l'exception
peut-être des régions du nord-est en
gros jusqu'au 13 février
le temps sera froid comme ces jours ci
il y aura des éclaircies dans le midi et
puis après ça jusqu'à la fin du mois des
pluies et des nuages partout de la neige
en montagne mais les températures seront
supérieurs d'une façon générale à celle
d'un mois de février normal